speaking of which amy's blood type
god i don't know i have to look it up at
the house you don't know if she has
friends you don't know what she does all
day and you don't know your wife's blood
type sure y'all are married
that is ben affleck in the movie gone
girl whose character becomes the prime
suspect after his wife amy disappears
the movie is based on the new york times
mega best seller of the same name it's a
book that came out 10 years ago and it
marked the anniversary a new edition of
gone girl is being released with scenes
that were never published before author
gillian flynn joins us now with her only
broadcast interview she's going to read
one of those passages
but before we get to that good morning
thank you for being here thank you for
having me here after all this time 10
years wow when you think about the
legacy of this book what is it
i think about
i mean the thing i'm proudest of is it
opened a lot of doors for other
books that similarly wanted to deal with
female protagonists who were not so nice
because when i first
tried selling my very first book which
was sharp objects you would not have
believed the number of publishers that
turned us down because they said
men don't want to read books by women
wow and
women don't want to read books about
women that they can't aspire to be like
wow that aren't likable wow and so the
competition
of these female characters
it sets you back a little bit yeah i
mean yeah i mean i at the time i thought
i don't think that's true right so
originality is risky then originality is
risky
when your book first came out there was
really nothing like it and even since
you know no one says if you like gone
girl read this because there was nothing
like like what you had done
you know and i think even
even more today it's a little trickier i
think the publishing market's getting a
little more nervous and i think people
want
you know do you have a platform or are
you
do you set settle comfortably in this
sort of genre and uh here i had i'd
written a book where
it's a whodunit
where you find out who done it halfway
through
and
um
told by two pretty unlikable narrators
and you know all these
kind of different things but i knew
all i knew when i finished writing it
was
i would read this book
yeah now speaking of this book there's
something special about this edition
right you've added in um never before
published excerpts from this book um but
you have a section that you're going to
re read to us right from the perspective
of this is it cross-legged and like a
little circle yeah right yeah by the
library story time can we get some
popcorn this is from the perspective of
amy the movie that's decorating all
right shall we do it yes yeah
yeah so my thought was
10th anniversary very cool to reissue it
but
i always tell people how do you know
when they ask me how do you write and i
say you know you write by making a lot
of mistakes
and i thought well why don't i prove it
okay
um
and it's basically figuring out your
character as you go along and so this
was a very
early version of amazing aim of amy okay
explain myself explain myself explain
myself in a way my parents approved
a way that made them believe they were
creating the perfect child
i do believe they had the best of
intentions to create an incredibly happy
super productive thoughtful and
proactive child
what they did was create a bit of a
monster it became entirely impossible to
be me
my parents great experiment failed
rather than develop a personality of my
own i learned to mimic the kind of
personality i thought suitable for the
occasion i could do almost anything
think almost anything i could smell out
what other people thought and wanted and
hoped for
and then if i deemed it worthwhile
i could give them the person they wanted
for a child a student a friend and later
a lover
they created a perfectly whole human
as long as you were looking at me from
the outside the inside it was quite
wonderfully empty
what does it mean to you gillian as you
sit here today when publisher after
publisher told you men don't a want to
read a book written by women that
surprises me and two that women didn't
want to read this kind of book six
million books later and now your 10th
anniversary and you're still adding
something new what does this mean to you
personally and how has it changed your
life the movie and the book
for me it
it's mostly very fortifying i mean it
mostly
is that idea i had been a reader
voracious reader my whole life and had
when i had started my first novel
thought i would really like to write a
female
narrator who's not perfect yeah who's
got
lots of troubles
very often
not likable and um does the wrong things
and i thought you know
the anti-hero has been around as a
staple of literature for a zillion years
you should feel very fortified you john
grisham walked in and said hi john i'm
john grisham
it was nice to see the exchanges yeah it
was amazing yeah and you got powerhouse
you are your own first reader you gotta
trust your instincts uh gillian flynn
you did that 10th anniversary of gone
girl on sale right now